[Musique]
alors voilà je me suis réveillé avec une
amnésie carabinée dans un bled paumé et
avec pour seul indice sûrement passé le
nom et l'adresse paris à l'intérieur de
cette casquette du coup je suis allé à
l'appartement et c'est là que je suis
tombé sur toi et ton agrafeuse arrête de
parler d une alice et la société oil
hallucinations donc tu es un pikachu qui
parle qui est amnésique qui est accro à
la caféine je peux arrêter quand je veux
c'est qu'une question volonté une autre
tournée et de double expresso en seria
peut-être car il est allé trop loin qui
s'est frotté à des gens dangereux tu
vois ce que je veux dire écoute tu peux
parler aux humains je peux parler aux
pokémon alors si tu veux retrouver ton
vieux on va devoir s'entraider non j'ai
pas besoin d'un pokémon mais si je te
dis que je suis un détective de talent
mais indice c'est quoi vous à harry est
encore en vie affaire classée
mais l' enquête reste ouverte tant que
je les parent isolé
c'est parti tu es lorgner harry a simulé
sa propre mort ou alors quelqu'un a
simulé laborde ary
[Musique]
ou alors harry a simulé la mort de
quelqu'un d'autre
la dernière théorie tient pas la route
[Musique]
non
tu t'en doutes je vais déjà réglé son
compte à ce pour des lots si c'est une
simple formalité
mon pote tu fais quoi là quand il ya des
gens ça me bloque samoa tattoo dessus
pika pika
[Musique]
c'est un coup théâtre travail accrue
quatre bleus ils vous appellent enfin ne
lui dit pas ça il prend le moteur vite
bloc le stop and on s'est pris une
grosse gamelle la team
ils auraient dû mettre un casque